en el siglo 18 los románticos alemanes
introdujeron la palabra safe Gates Esta
es conocida en español como el espíritu
de un tiempo en la actualidad Google
recoge esa esencia y cada año hace su
lista de lo más buscado son las
preguntas de la humanidad y este 2022 la
palabra más buscada fue guardell un
juego virtual en el que cada día hay una
nueva palabra de cinco letras que se
puede adivinar en seis intentos en
segundo y quinto lugar destaca la
movilización de los internautas indios
con búsquedas de partidos de India
contra Inglaterra y Sudáfrica en Cricket
el tercer puesto fue para Ucrania con
auge después de la invasión de Rusia del
24 de febrero
en cuarta posición figura la Reina
Isabel II Quien murió el 8 de septiembre
después de 70 años al frente de la
corona de Reino Unido entre el top de
búsquedas también hubo espacio para
América Latina la película de Disney y
Encanto sobre la familia Madrigal
colombiana ocupó el quinto lugar en
búsquedas de cine
en gastronomía el vuelo caseiro fue la
tercera receta más buscada es la forma
en Brasil de nombrar a una torta casera
también Brasil posee el cuarto monumento
más buscado del mundo es el Cristo
Redentor de Río de Janeiro una de las
siete maravillas del mundo
búsquedas entre las que Google destaca
una frase que ha aumentado más que nunca
Cómo puedo cambiar porque el ser humano
continúa con la ambición de reinventarse
a sí mismo y también al mundo